well russia's invasion of ukraine has
alarmed countries across eastern europe
with fears they could be dragged into
the conflict as well estonia shares a
border with russia it's been a full
member of nato and the european union
since 2004. it's already sent more than
230 million dollars worth of military
aid to ukraine that's point eight
percent of its gdp the highest of any
country
joining us now on the news hour is a
lark harris who's the president of
estonia he's live from the world
economic forum in davos switzerland mr
president thank you so much for being
with us on al jazeera
you you live in a dangerous neighborhood
today mr president how worried are you
about the risk of the war in ukraine to
your country and how do you assess your
current relationship with not just nato
but also with russia
well at the moment there is no immediate
threat to estonia because first of all
we are a member of nato and this
umbrella will probably defend us and not
only nato
troops in estonia but but also but also
ourselves so
it's uh
i just lost my my air piece
so uh it is one thing and of course uh
the difference is that uh
ukraine is not a nato member so you
can't compare the situations but of
course as far as russia is concerned we
have warned it already several times
that this kind of thing might happen but
nobody did expect that that
they attack ukraine right in in this way
and this kind of
war will start
but
russia will stay our neighbor and we
have to be
um
prepared and to defend ourselves so uh
and the relations with nato is extremely
good and
it's even better than our neighbors
finland and sweden are actually joining
uh joining nato so
a security situation is going to be
different than it was let's say five
tens or fifteen years ago you talked
about finland and
russia i mean at the moment not so many
countries actually have relations with
russia right so
first of all it's important to stop this
war which is in ukraine and this
aggression and then we can start talking
what's uh happening next mr president
you talked about finland
and sweden there and there have been
splits within nato about uh the way
forward finland and sweden want to join
the alliance but turkey has been opposed
to it as you know
uh there's been a meeting in ankara
there's a meeting in ankara later today
do you think we can expect a
breakthrough on that and do you think
president erdogan of turkey's concerns
about
finland and sweden joining nato are
legitimate
well of course it's a very early stage
as well as finland and sweden
joining nato so of course
some countries like like turkey they
have their own concern but it's very
easy very difficult to say at this stage
what's going to happen um but i'm pretty
much convinced that
uh by the end of the day or by the end
of the year
these worries are not worries anymore
and
and turkey is not against finland and
sweden joining nato
divisions however also in the eu within
the european union hungary is blocking a
six package of sanctions against russia
that includes a russian oil ban
how do you convince president obama that
this is the way to go
well we have to convince because it is
important
to
to implement this uh
six package and even if it takes time
times we can also have what means
half a package to be implemented and and
uh keep talking to uh to some countries
who are not very favor of this kind of
sanctions as well as oil and and gas is
concerned so it's an improv working
process and we'll see how it goes right
the growing concerns mr president about
global food supplies because grains from
ukraine are not moving what role can
your country estonia play in this
of course it's uh it's an important
issue because we are might be in a tough
step of another humanitarian crisis if
ukraine is not able to provide grain to
developing countries mostly uh in africa
so we have to find means to uh to get
this plane out of the country and
baltic states as well together with
ukraine uh discussing how to use
railroad
and and the baltics the harbors baltic
sea harbors to get grain out of uh
ukraine because there are
about 50 million
metric tons of
grain in ukraine and waiting to uh to
get out because they don't have storages
to to give them in ukraine
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak to us mr president allah carris is
the president of estonia joining us
there from the world economic
forum in davos switzerland we appreciate
your time thank you
thank you very much